voilà
[Musique]
mais tu manges que tu as envie de manger
il y a de la viande il y a des carottes
aujourd'hui contraint de baisser le
rideau alors très touché et préoccupé
par ses témoignages bouleversants Cyril
Hanouna et l'équipe de TPMP ont donc
décidé de leur venir en aide en lançant
ce soir l'opération tapant du pain sur
la table
qu'est-ce que tu fais habillé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à l'instant avec mes équipes donc voilà
c'est juste que un moment c'est moi je
suis moi ça me rend fou moi je vous dis
ça me rend fou de voir Roger qui va se
retrouver à chercher du travail à 59 ans
mais c'est que mon marche sur la tête
excusez-moi pour aider tout le monde
arrêtez c'est c'est on devient fou dans
ce pays ce pays tout marche à l'envers
excusez-moi c'est c'est n'importe quoi
unique
ubiquité
c'est entre une casserole un dispositif
sonore amplificateur de son secure des
patates dedans c'est une sorte de
féminisme en quelque sorte bon je
remballe dialogue dedans casserole
dehors mais pas de face à face entre le
président et ses centaines de
manifestants bruyant on agit au sens où
la presse rendra compte d'une action
collective en nous chanterons le temps
des casseroles au gouvernement
qui donne la rougeole
feront tous la tête
[Musique]
à force de taper tout le monde
les ministres auront la peur du sortir
il est casseroles seront des banderoles
quand nous chanterons le temps des
casseroles
dialoguer aller au contact c'est ce que
demandait manuel Macron dans une lettre
adressée à ses troupes un an après sa
réélection rien ne serait pire que de
déserter le terrain dans les semaines
qui viennent comme moi vous allez à
nouveau sillonner le pays
visite chahuté hier pour le ministre de
la Santé François Brown du côté de
Poitiers mais aussi pour
Eric Dupont-Moretti dans la Sarthe
de retour de Lyon pas peine d'y aller se
voit accueilli dans une gare parisienne
par des manifestants presque au même
moment dans la boîte mail de 200000
militants Renaissance tombe cette
missive du chef de l'État rien ne serait
pire que de laisser couvrir la voie des
progressistes par les cris des
démagogues donnez bien du mal
corvetter
corps VT on essaie
faites faire une corvée
le sol c'est tu vas corvetter un peu
hein ça te fera du bien je l'appelle le
fossoyeur du social tout ce qui est
spatiale et il attaque des 90 ans
aujourd'hui j'en ai mené des lutins mais
voir ça comme ça aujourd'hui on a jamais
vu
Emmanuel Macron appelle ses soutiens
sillonnés le pays occupé le terrain une
opération en son et en images une
nouvelle campagne d'affichage qui vante
le bilan du président sera lancé le 7
mai franchement vous connaissez les
codes de la télévision et je vous en
remercie c'est pas le cas de tout le
monde mais
on vous écoute et je voulais aussi vous
remercier de m'avoir invité parce que
c'est pas quotidien qu'il aurait fait
mais d'ailleurs je le répète pour des
raisons écologiques bien sûr ils sont en
vacances donc ça nous enfer en même
temps d'ailleurs
pour une fois qu'on a un président qui a
des couilles qui fait des réformes on va
prendre quand même pas s'en plaindre on
voit que des images sur vos chaînes de
télé là où il y a des 20 mecs qui tapent
dans une casserole non il y a des gens
qui sont là pour soutenir président qui
sont d'accord avec un certain nombre de
trucs il y a une période difficile à
passer et je pense que le président
saura trouver avec les mois qui vont
venir trouver les bons mots
[Musique]
il aurait pas pu faire The Voice comment
vous expliquer le fait que vous soyez
presque 10 fois moins nombreux que les
manifestants qui sont à quelques
centaines de mètres et qui eux ont des
casseroles font du bruit et lui réserve
un accueil particulier parce que ils
sont payés et pas nous ils sont payés
par qui
ça va en faire bondir certains mais
j'aime bien Roussel et Bardella qui sont
à deux trucs complètement opposés parce
que dans leur discours il y a quelque
chose de qui prend en compte les gens
c'est con ça les gens les gens du peuple
parce que moi je suis le je suis le
porte drapeau un peu de ces gens-là
c'est le blaireau tu sais ce qu'ils
disent le blaireau le français
un des fidèles de l'émission il y arrive
il se gourde de côté c'est fou ça
ça imprime pas c'est dingue c'est
problème direction mais je pense
problème de quoi
j'avais
pas du tout entendu
c'est un choix c'est un choix pertinent
de votre part pas du tout mais le coup
de foudre après on regarde pas enfin
c'était pas franchement motif d'homme
à la base à la Michel Boujenah